Checa tiene un nuevo presidente el país
europeo se decantó por Peter Pavel un
general retirado de 61 años con
experiencia en la otan Muchas gracias Me
gustaría dar las gracias No solo a los
que me han votado sino también a los que
no me han votado pero han venido a votar
[Aplausos]
porque está claro que les importa la
democracia y lo que ocurre en este país
en una participación récord del 70,2% y
con más del 58% de los votos le ganó a
su contendor el empresario
multimillonario y exprimer ministro
andrei babis quien aceptó su derrota
ante Pavel
felicito al Señor Peter Pavel por su
Victoria acepto La derrota y le felicito
por convertirse en el próximo presidente
de la República Checa presidente
[Aplausos]
me gustaría que fuera el presidente de
todos los ciudadanos de la República
Checa upchano
tras conseguir el apoyo del gobierno de
Centro derecha que sacó Babys del poder
en las elecciones parlamentarias de 2021
estuvo en el ejército en misión de paz
en los balcanes en los 90 y dirigió El
Estado Mayor checo desde 2012 en la
alianza atlántica para terminar como
presidente del comité militar de la
Organización de donde se retiró en 2018
Paula asumirá el cargo en marzo
sustituyendo al saliente Milo seman
quien fue criticado por entablar
relaciones más fuertes con Beijing y
Moscú algo que supone un giro para el
país el nuevo presidente es abiertamente
proeuropeo respaldando la adopción del
euro quiere mantener a la República
Checa en la otan y el apoyo a Ucrania en
medio de la guerra Por ende su Victoria
alegró a bolodimir zelanski quien lo
felicitó vía Twitter los presidentes
checos no tienen muchas obligaciones
cotidianas Aunque eligen a los primeros
ministros y a los directores de los
bancos centrales y pueden presionar al
gobierno en sus políticas